you know of course you're going to hear
it if you're going to a Halloween party
tonight maybe you were at a Halloween
party over the weekend it's Michael
Jackson's Thriller now the question is
Heather Mills do you know all the moves
I don't no but I know who does Candace
Charles learning the moves showing it
off at Dance Dynamics in downtown
Summerlin I love that you've got their
team of dancers there to kind of move
and groove to MJ it's always safer to
dance in a crowd Candace
it really is especially what some
competitive dancers they really know
what they're doing and if you're joining
us from the five o'clock hour you're in
luck you're going to see the rest of
dance moves here shortly get on up and
join us right now I'm joined with Paige
Wilson who's actually the director here
so tell us a little bit about what we're
going to be doing now all right so
earlier we learned the first part of
Thriller so we're gonna pick it up from
the chorus okay uh just keep going from
there perfect perfect okay so what's
next all right we're gonna do a little
jump a little jump we're gonna look to
the right left right left we're going to
show our shoulders shrug shoulders
okay
one more time one more toe okay I know
we're gonna hold this pose for two
counts I like the smart guys yeah and
then Michael Jackson
yeah okay we're gonna come up like our
zombies
and we're gonna go into the classic you
guys should know this part
yeah Anthony Henry yeah
okay and we're gonna end with a nice
little shimmy and it down and then we're
going to turn into our zombies in the
graveyard and we're gonna come after you
guys let's do it from the top here we go
ladies all right guys get on up enjoy
this right now here we go
and do a shake and do a shake and do a
shake and
Claws and close here we go thank you
Michael Jackson
all right
[Applause]
yes
all right I'm gonna let them keep on
doing it because they know what they're
doing but if you want to learn more
dances here at Dance Dynamics I got you
covered with those details on our
website newsnow.com coming up there's
one more Dance I'm sure you're going to
see this Halloween so I got you covered
with those dance moves you guys don't
want to miss it for now live from Dance
Dynamics in downtown Summerlin I'm
Candace Charles eight news now here we
go they're good okay she's got some
boobs I think I could do the Monster
Mash yeah right because it is just kind
of like well I feel like Candace kind of
knows the moves already I feel like she
could teach the crowd she like sneakily
already learned it yeah she went in
there and teaching them that's how it
goes it looks good I